Since we're looking for roots, once again we set y equal to zero. Which is just
going to leave a 10, on the left side of the equation, and change nothing about
the right side. Now we need to move toward getting x by itself. You can notice
that I actually didn't use the quadratic formula, in solving this equation.
Instead, I just undid all the operations that had been performed on x on the
right side of the equation. Eventually this led me to the answer of x equals 3
plus or minus i times the square root of 5. Now one thing to note about the way
that I've written this answer. You'll see that I wrote i in front of the radical
sign, whereas we'd normally write in the form a plus bi, where the real
coefficient of the imaginary portion comes in front of the number i. However, to
avoid confusion as to whether or not the i belongs under the radical sign, it's
often written in front of the square root sign instead. This is similar to if we
had something like 3 times the root of five, writing the number this way is
usually the convention. Rather than this way, just to make perfectly clear what
doesn't belong under the radical sign. Either way though, with the i as the
first factor, or the i coming after the square root of 5, is mathematically
correct.